let's take a look at a united states one
dollar bill what is it that gives this
thing value you can give it to people
and get back you know food that you can
eat or things that you can use and
things of hard value but what is it
about this little piece of paper that
makes it valuable i guess it's not paper
is it it's it's cotton something like
that right but the question stands right
like what makes this flimsy little thing
that doesn't seem to have any use in its
own right valuable well one kind of
interesting exercise is to step back in
time a little bit and take a look at
what the very very first united states
dollars looked like so i have here one
of the very first that was printed and
let's zoom in on it and kind of read
some of the words associated with it so
if we zoom in let's just say towards the
very top here
notice that it says silver certificate
silver certificate up here at the top so
what does that mean
well if we zoom out a little bit it says
it says
that
this certifies that there has been
deposited in the treasury of the united
states of america and then the sentence
kind of continues in an awkward way
below
one silver dollar payable to the bearer
on demand so what that means what this
dollar originally represented was the
fact that you were going to be able to
turn in this bill for a silver dollar
this piece of paper in theory could be
turned in to the united states treasury
which guaranteed that it had in its
deposits a silver dollar an actual piece
of silver and i'll show what one of
those looked like in just a moment that
it would return to you for this bill
so in a sense what gave it value was
this guarantee that you could turn it
into silver if you wanted so this way
you could trade this with other people
as if it was a piece of silver because
if you gave it to someone that person
now being the bearer on demand
could then in theory turn this in and
get a silver dollar as a result and the
reason for even having this paper money
and printing these bills is that it was
pretty inconvenient to always lug around
actual pieces of silver in actual pieces
of metal and this would be especially
true in the case of even higher amounts
so for example
here we have a ten thousand dollar bill
um something you don't really see too
often and if we zoom in and kind of see
the guarantees that are written on this
guy it's actually very similar but it's
this is instead in gold instead of
silver it says that ten thousand dollars
in gold are payable to the bearer on
demand as authorized by law so kind of
legally backing up the idea that this
could be turned in for ten thousand
dollars worth of gold so that way people
could actually treat this as if it was
you know ten thousand dollars worth of
gold without having to lug around that
much money so what is it that you
actually got when you turned in you know
for one silver dollar or something like
that what is it that was payable on
demand
well you have what's another form of
money what you can use in commerce and
kind of trade with people as a medium of
exchange officially united states money
but the difference is that the piece of
money itself is the valuable metal it
actually is the silver so in theory if
you you know didn't trust the united
states government anymore you could melt
it down for just the pure silver and
maybe other countries still value that
silver and similarly there was there was
gold coins like this that people would
use like this right here is a gold coin
worth two and a half dollars so this is
something where the value is held within
it because presumably people value gold
and even if this didn't have a fancy you
know united states symbol all stamped
onto it it would be something valuable
because it's gold
and this kind of money this you know
gold coins or these silver coins has a
special kind of name
it's called commodity money
let's see commodity money
and basically what this means is that
the thing that you're using for money
the thing you're trading around has some
value in its own right even if it wasn't
money it would still be something
valuable this word here commodity uh
basically means just anything valuable
it could not only be you know silver or
gold but things like food or furniture
or
livestock these are commodities
and you know you could argue that silver
and gold
aren't valuable other than the fact that
people just like using them for trading
i mean they're kind of pretty and useful
for jewelry and there's some electronics
that use them but on the whole the main
reason that people value silver and gold
is because they're used for trading it's
kind of because other people value them
so it's a little bit weird that these
are the quintessential examples of
commodity money when in fact other
commodities you know like wheat or
oranges uh feel much more you know real
hard valuable something you can use in
its own right than the pieces of metal
but nevertheless these are these are
commodities and the other form of money
here where you have something that you
could in theory exchange to a bank and
then the bank would return to you you
know the actual silver that it
represents the commodity that it
represents you know in this case silver
these are called commodity-backed money
backed
because their value is being backed up
by the value of whatever commodity they
represent another term that you might
hear for them is representative money
because they are representing
another good representative
in this case silver or gold
but in the early days of money like
thousands of years ago you would have
representative money like the shekel
which represented a certain
a certain weight of barley so it doesn't
just have to be silver or gold sometimes
you have
you have money that represents a
different sort of commodity so
commodity-backed representative this is
the kind of like old-style united states
or other countries money a lot of people
had commodity-backed money um but in
modern terms it's common not to have
either of those you just have this bill
that's not backed up by silver you could
not turn this in and get silver as a
result and this this is termed fiat
money fiat
money
and this word fiat kind of means a
decree or a declaration so it's like the
united states government has declared
that this is money and just by declaring
that it's money presumably that gives
its value so it kind of feels much more
hollow in comparison to you know
commodity money or commodity-backed
money but there's a couple a couple hard
things backing this up one of them if
you if we kind of zoom in on some of the
words here um
if you go you see that it says this note
is legal tender so here i'll write that
down this note is legal tender for all
that's public and private and i talked
about the idea of legal tender in the
last video and how that actually you
know gives a little bit of clout to this
being valuable as long as you trust that
the government will enforce its laws as
as it claims that it will
but for the most part uh what makes this
stuff valuable is the fact that other
people trust it right the reason that
you value having a dollar bill is
because you know you can give it to most
people and they are willing to trade you
valuable things for it and at the end of
the day that's what was making you know
silver dollars or these ten thousand
dollar you know gold gold notes valuable
because almost no one would actually
trade it in for the silver because why
would you it's just as good and it's a
little bit more convenient to just trade
around the bill itself so once that's
actually in the psychology of a society
and once everyone kind of is used to the
idea of trading around this paper
representative money in order to be able
to get things of value it's not actually
a huge leap to just have the paper that
you're trading around as long as
everyone else trusts it and it still
serves those those functions of money
that i talked about in previous videos
it's a medium of exchange and you can
store this for value right the paper is
not going to degrade it's something you
can store and it does give a unit of
value assigning a number to to various
goods out there but it is it is just
something that was declared it's not an
actual hard good and this is kind of an
important distinction to recognize is
that fiat money
really does mean it's just trusted it's
just taken on faith that people will
find this valuable but for that matter
that's also true of silver and gold
right like it's just taken on faith that
if you melted down the silver other
people would find that valuable
and same goes for gold and in fact in
some you know even though a lot of
western cultures valued gold a lot there
were other cultures uh that they might
find like in asia
that
didn't value gold in the same way and
decide why why is everyone getting all
up in a fuss about this this fancy medal
so this idea of having money that we use
basically because we trust that others
will find it valuable isn't actually
that absurd and as long as it serves
those same three basic functions of
money you can have a working society you
know barring things like hyperinflation
that that makes it so that it no longer
serves those functions of money see you
next video